for the first time in three years
tourists can enjoy an unrestricted
easter holiday the national tourist
board visit england estimates that
almost seven and a half million visitors
are booked stays in the uk this weekend
bringing in almost 2 billion pounds in
revenue for resorts like scarborough
we're very happy i mean it has been
three years since we've been able to
stand here on a good friday and welcome
our visitors to scarborough and the
sun's shining it's a beautiful day and
it's just brilliant to have our folk
back where they should be
for many foreign travel is still too
uncertain or too expensive
it's really nice to have the freedom and
enjoy enjoy your time out
we're actually just on a little easter
break really all together so we're
yeah it's the first time in a while
no i don't want to go abroad anyway you
know let's spend it at home yeah
uk has got so many beautiful places yeah
yeah yeah very true as well i'm going
abroad later this year but we're coming
to finally in august for a week-long
holiday then as well so you're still
enjoying the staycations absolutely yeah
yeah
much of the pre-weekend travel problems
have now eased off good news for those
heading to places like chew valley lake
in somerset
hope you'll enjoy the ride
and of course whatever the destination
the good weather helps enormously
the sun is shining people are coming
everyone's enjoying themselves we've got
lots to offer here in scarborough and
it's uh it's been a really great weekend
so far
tourism bosses know that making sure
there are plenty of attractions for
their customers will require further
investment
there may have been problems and delays
on the cross channel ferry crossings
this easter bank holiday but here in
scarborough it's plain sailing
[Music]
not plain sailing for the thousands of
football fans heading from the north
west to wembley though disruption to the
rail services from manchester and
liverpool not ideal on an fa cup
semi-final weekend
we're at wembley we're going to enjoy
my son my grandchildren what more can
you want we just drove down so i just
like a big weekend of it anyway it's a
nice lovely day i'm here a lot earlier
than what i expected the pressure is now
on for british tourist destinations to
keep the momentum going to make sure
that staycations weren't just something
we did during a pandemic
fraser moored sky news scarborough